I have loved "Beauty and the Beast" since I was about 4 years old
I just fell in love with Belle
She was this feisty young woman who spoke her mind
I know what she meant to me as a young girl
When you love something that much, you really wanna do it justice
It's just amazing
[I want adventure in the great wide somewhere]
Hello?
[I want it more than I can tell]
Come into the light!
[For once it might be grand]
What if she is the one?
[To have someone understand]
Pleased to meet you!
[I want so much more than they've got planned]
Disney's Beauty and the Beast
Rated PG
(Beauty and the Beast Prologue playing)
Papa?
Belle, this castle is alive
(Roar)
Do you wish to take your father's place?
Come into the light!
(Tale as old a time playing)
Hello!
You can talk!
Well, of COURSE he can talk!
What if she is the one?
The one who'll break the spell?
The master's not as terrible as he appears
I say we kill the beast!
No!
Think of the one thing you've always wanted
And feel it in your heart.
Disney's Beauty and the Beast